[Music]
jd is with us in lincoln nebraska hi jd
how are you
wonderful how are you guys better than i
deserve what's up
well i'm one of the few that you have
talked about that has inherited millions
uh which
turned me into a millionaire um but i
own
one of a piece of property that
i would like to
sell um either to the partnership that
already exists and let them own it or
have the have the whole thing liquidated
and turn it into put my portion into
mutual funds
because i don't see the return that i
would like to see off of the piece of
property but i don't know that i can
make it work
and i'm just looking for guidance okay
um so the the partners that are in this
are your other relatives that inherited
it with you correct okay and how many of
them are there
um
there are two others
but we are not equal owners um my uncle
and i are
larger share owners than my
other aunt
and what what percentage do you own
41
okay and how is this structured um is it
an llc or do each of you just
individually own a portion no it is an
llc okay does the llc uh documents allow
for sale of shares
as long as all three parties agree
okay all right
so um
how is the relationship with your uncle
and your aunt
uh the relationship is good i don't know
if the
uh interest to buy me out will be there
i have been told that to sell the this
piece of property it would have to bring
a certain dollar amount and i don't know
that we're there
to sell it outright for that
okay
well i i think i'd start the
conversation with them and just say i'm
one out i went out it's no disrespect to
you all or to the family or to the
person who left it to me there's no
disrespect to the memory of what's going
on it's an investment decision for me
and i want out i want to sell my 41
now how are we going to do this
do you guys want to put the whole thing
on the market or can i discount it
and let youtube buy me out or one of you
buy me out and i would discount it uh
reasonably it's found money you didn't
uh quote unquote earn it i don't want
you to cut it in half
but if you you know what is your 41
approximately worth
uh about 590 000. okay and so if you got
490 for it i wouldn't be mad
okay i just made that up
but i mean my point is a substantial
discount but not a huge huge huge thing
so if you guys are get me out i'll give
you a deal
because i need to move on
this is the right thing to do and i
don't think you guys want to sell it
based on the price you think you can get
that you want to demand for it that's a
signal you don't really want to sell it
because it's not going to bring that and
i want out
and so let's start a conversation how
how we can get me out do we sell it
or do i discount it to you guys and let
you guys buy me out how can we work this
out let's start to talk about it and i
think you'll see what's going on